there cannot be peace without first a
great suffering
the greater the suffering the greater
the peace the end you always fear is
coming it's coming and blood will be on
your way I prayed to go that it wasn't
true
Solomon Lane escaped in Paris now the
world is at risk this is the CIA's
mission you use a scalpel I prefer a
hammer
he's not just some observer he's an
assassin
I trust anybody outside in this room
you go ro he's been authorized to hunt
you down and kill you
that's the job
no hard feelings
[Music]
what are you waiting for
I'm jumping out a window stops Ethan
hands everyone I ever cared about
you don't understand what you're
involved in you need to walk away
we are
maybe
[Music]
accept it either you've lost this one
was tennis time
what's done is done when we say it's
done
Showtime oh my god
your mission should you choose to accept
it I wonder did you have to choose not
to the end norm was feared is coming
and the blood will be on your hands the
fallout off of all your good intentions
you had a terrible choice to make in
Berlin one life over millions and now
the world is at risk this is the CIA's
mission if he had held on to the
plutonium we wouldn't be having this
conversation this Tim you'd be dead yes
they would
that's the job you don't understand what
you're involved in you need to walk away
please don't make me code for you how
many times has Huntz governments
betrayed him disavowed him cast him
aside how long before a man like that
has had enough
[Music]
we are
so how is he oh you know same always
there
what the hell is he doing find it best
not to hook
you